So the first one is easy to see. The size of a minimum vertex cover is 2
because you can just take this one here and this one here, and all edges are covered.
Of course I constructed it that way. And that is also the size of the greedy solution.
Because what the greedy algorithm will do is it will look at the whole graph
and then say, oh which vertex could I use to cover the most edges?
And actually this vertex here is next to 7 uncovered edges, and this one here as well
so it will just choose 1 of them. Put that one into the vertex cover, say, and then
in the next round all of these edges here are already covered, so it will just say,
oh, here's another vertex I can use to cover 7 edges. So let's take that one because
all of the other vertices, they can just cover 2 or 1 edge. So after executing this loop
just twice, the algorithm is already done and it has even found an optimum solution.
Now the Take 2 algorithm, on the other hand, well that looks a bit stupid
compared to the greedy algorithm for this graph here, because what would it do?
Well, it takes any uncovered edge--it doesn't really matter which one. So let's say
it takes this one here, and then it will put this vertex here into the solution set
and this vertex here. So all of those edges here are covered, and that one here as well.
And, well it's not done yet, so it will have to choose another uncovered edge,
let's say it's that one here, and again put 2 vertices into the solution set and then
all edges are covered. So here the Take 2 algorithm, which you know by now is a
factor-2 approximation algorithm, actually performs as bad as it can. So it really
maxes out this factor-2 leeway that it is given.